the main thing i want to talk to you
about as as a former governor yourself
um it's been it's been an interesting
year
for governors in general republican
governors
um some of them with respect to the
covid
lockdowns i think have been quite
impressive obviously desantis in florida
gnome and south dakota and others
pushing back against it others other
other republican governors not not so
willing to uh to push back and have sort
of gone along with the so-called experts
and done whatever they
were told and then and then that kind of
gives way to
um this issue with gender we've seen a
push
across the country uh on a state
wide level of trying to pass
bills to kind of put a halt um
if only temporarily to the march of the
left gender madness in their states
and so there's been bills uh banning
males from competing against females and
female sports
and then in arkansas there was a bill
that was supposed to stop
uh children from having their genitals
mutilated
or being drugged you know because their
gender confused
but in both of those cases we know
governor noman south dakota and governor
hutchinson in
arkansas rejected or vetoed
those bills um and i first i'm just
broadly speaking i'm interested to get
your thoughts on that what
do you think there's is there any
defending this you know they had their
reasons they thought it was
government overstepping its bounds and
it was kind of a rejection of our
limited government principles and so on
um what's what's your take on that
no i don't think so i mean i think the
the fundamentals i tell kids on campus
all the time beyond just this
issue the difference between the left
and the right is the left wants the
government to tell you what to do when
to do and how to do it and everything in
every way
our view at least my view as i
articulate is
as long as you don't hurt the health and
safety of your neighbor go out and do
your own thing live your own life pursue
your own dream
in the larger context but we're talking
about minors that's a whole different
ballgame
there's the obvious reason why all
throughout society we have protections
for children for those under the age of
18. and so it only makes sense my kids
are now 25 and 26 i got nieces who are
17 and 14. i think any of us who are
parents know particularly in the teen
years how our kids will change their
mind 20 times a day
let alone you know over the period of a
month or a year
or or you know early on in their
lifetime so
i i do think it makes sense that we're
protecting particularly against these
supposed woke
radical uh parents who are
allowing kids to go to great extremes to
try and show
how accepting they are not understanding
that
when you're talking about physical
changes when you're talking about things
involving
medical procedures medications other
things those are things that
are almost irreversible and again kids
are going to
change their minds on any number of
things
let's be careful what happens there and
on the larger context on
what happened in south dakota and what's
being proposed and advocated for in
other states
i think anyone who's ever watched
high school and junior high and even
earlier sports know
there's a reason why boys and girls
don't compete against each other
it wouldn't be fair there's other level
levels where
where young women are actually far ahead
their male counterparts when it comes to
their
development intellectually in the
classroom other areas
that boys will take some time to catch
up on but physically
it makes no sense for boys and girls to
be competing against each other
and no matter what you think about the
larger issue of transgenderism
the bottom line is there's no way that
someone who is physically born
a young man should be competing against
a girl and
i think governors of any party but
particularly republican governors
should recognize that stand up for that